okay we have really substantive
follow-up to a major story from either
last week or the week before not too
long ago you might remember that i
reported to you
that two prosecutors working on the
manhattan district attorney's criminal
probe of donald trump's organization
resigned they just they said we quit
we're not doing it anymore and we went
that story this was from okay february
23rd so two weeks ago and in this
original reporting
two prosecutors resigned
um this was a years old probe
we didn't know why
we as far as was announced the
investigation was still ongoing and it
was sort of a real question mark and at
the time my speculation remember
speculation was
these prosecutors realized
they're not going to indict trump
they're not going to charge trump and
they felt
my work is being done in vain i'm
getting the hell out of here that was my
speculation and i identified it as such
to be clear the speculation on the right
was
they quit
because they knew there was no evidence
against the trump organization and they
felt they were being railroaded into
there was no evidence of that
there was no evidence of my hypothesis
but i argued to you that my hypothesis
is far more plausible
and my hypothesis has now been
vindicated and vindicated exactly
prosecutors resigned says a new article
after new york d.a said
he wasn't prepared to move forward with
the indictment of donald trump we now
know the reason and
i got lucky it happened to be the reason
i said
two top prosecutors leading the criminal
probe into trump and his business
resigned after the manhattan district
attorney said he was not prepared to
authorize an indictment against the
former president a person familiar with
the investigation said
and there it is
carrie dunn and mark pomerantz two
senior prosecutors on the team resigned
last month one day after manhattan
district attorney alvin bragg informed
them
he's not prepared to move forward with
criminal charges the resignations
followed weeks of internal debate and
discussion over the strength of evidence
and whether it could pass the hurdle of
proving a crime now i want to be really
clear
it's possible
that the d.a is correct we don't have
enough to prove a trump crime here that
may well be but the question was why
would they resign would they resign
because there's nothing here to
investigate doesn't seem likely because
they've been investigating for a long
time if that was the reason they would
have known there was no evidence a long
time ago or is it more likely that they
were getting frustrated with the fact
that they've been investigating for so
long they have what they might see as a
solid case built up
and yet no one is willing to indict
and that appears to be it now
interestingly uh there's some detail
here about why
this is
um
the abrupt resignation okay where's the
section here
it was originally started by sai vance
we know that the new york times first
reported that the resignations followed
a decision by bragg to stop presenting
evidence to the grand jury
the strength of the evidence against
trump has been debated by attorneys in
the office for months some prosecutors
including the two that resigned believe
there was sufficient evidence to charge
trump while others including career
prosecutors were skeptical they could
get a conviction because of the
difficulty in proving criminal intent
that's another thing we've talked about
a lot of the crimes here that donald
trump could be charged with
really require you to show what his
state of mind and intent was
and that can be very very difficult
on the one hand some prosecutors believe
trump speaks with a lot of hyperbole but
it wasn't clear that they could show he
acted with intent to defraud
there's also a very important piece here
about michael cohen
and this i think we should talk about a
little more multiple factors were at
play including lack of key trump
organization insider cooperating uh with
insiders cooperating with the
investigation who at trial could walk
the jury through the evidence the
possible value of using michael cohen
trump's former personal attorney who in
testimony before congress alleged trump
inflated and devalued assets for his
advantage was discussed with the team
cohen pleaded guilty to nine charges
including lying to congress he was once
close to trump but his conviction and
public statements critical of trump
would give the defense ammunition to aim
to discredit him
that is a very very interesting piece of
this
the idea is
if you you don't have a cooperating
witness from inside trump's business you
do have all sorts of claims from michael
cohen but michael cohen if you read
between the lines what they're saying is
would be easy to discredit
and destroy his credibility in a
cross-examination on the basis that he
has perjured himself
he has uh lied he has a long history
of all of the trouble that ultimately
got him convicted
the counter to that be well those are
all crimes he committed
for donald trump but i think it's a very
legitimate question to say
what is a jury going to think
if michael cohen is their main witness
and is cross-examined about all the
times that he lied well so you told the
lie then how are we to believe that you
are telling the truth now etcetera
etcetera so the point here is
this is number one exactly what we
believe was going on prosecutors getting
sick of the fact that they're doing
their work
and nobody really seems willing to
prosecute that seems to be going on and
then number two this is why i continue
to say donald trump is not going to
spend a single day in prison and i
apologize to people who think i'm
causing that to be the truth
no prosecutors are listening to me
they're going to decide what to do
regardless of what i say i see it as a
very high bar to reach that a prosecutor
will say i'm going to be the first
the first
to indict
a former president
uh i think if one did it others would
fall but who is willing to be first we
haven't found anybody quite yet and
that's the latest with the prosecution
that's in manhattan there's georgia
southern district of new york there's
all these other things going on but at
least as far as what's going on in
manhattan a logical follow-up to the
story from uh february
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years
privacy lets me create virtual payment
cards with one click and when i use the
virtual card the money is taken out of
my bank account you can create multiple
cards delete them freeze them set a
spending limit on them let's say i'm
signing up for a free trial and it
requires a credit card privacy will
autofill a virtual card number and then
after signing up i can delete that
virtual card so i know i'm not going to
be charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video